no franchise has defined the xbox more
than halo the operatic series primarily
centered on the ongoing battle between
humanity and the alien covenant oh and
also the lovecraftian spores space
zombies that want nothing more than to
explode in your face at the worst
possible moment
you know normal sci-fi stuff with its
galaxy spanning story and genre defining
multiplayer it's fair to say that gaming
wouldn't be the same without master
chief good old chiefy so with halo
infinite set to release soon we're
looking back at the entire franchise and
ranking every mainline game in the
series so none of that spin-off nonsense
like spartan strike or halo wars though
those are excellent games in their own
right we see you halo wars 2 stans
we see you so fill up on bubble shields
and grab your assault rifles because
it's time to finish this fight
seriously
[Music]
number 7 halo 5 guardians sadly the
latest entry in the franchise is also
its weakest ahead of halo 5 guardian's
2015 release microsoft kicked off an
elaborate marketing campaign hinting
that the heroic master chief just like
bailey eilish might be the bad guy is
this
what you were looking for
indeed for most of the story the game
lets you play as spartan jameson lock as
he chases after the rogue chief but now
i must save us
from you
well
we say lets you play as lock
others may say force we found lock to be
a mostly one note protagonist especially
compared to master chief's much more
investing tale of attempting to rescue
his friend and rampant ai cortana come
home with us
it's not too late to stop this
stop
no john
this is too important to stop
still the campaign contained enthralling
set pieces numerous new locations and a
more open-ended level design allowing
players to choose their own paths
through the environment unfortunately
though halo 5 did not support split
screen leading to huge fan outcry and
microsoft promising that future halo
games like halo infinite will indeed
support the feature
the multiplayer however was some of the
franchise's most refined with the big
new addition of the moba style war zone
being especially well received although
even that garnered backlash due to its
use of rec packs which had players
spending real money to unlock items for
the first time in the series yet despite
the flaws halo 5 still managed to
innovate with its clambering system
which introduced a new level of speed
and verticality to halo something being
brought forward with halo infinite
number 6 halo 3 odst while 2009's halo 3
odst was originally conceived as a
bridge game between halo 3 and halo
reach it quickly turned into a full
release that remains a favorite for many
halo fans including yours truly set in
the runes of new mambasa after the
events of halo 3 you play as the rookie
a member of the orbital drop shock
troopers who after a landing gone wrong
is tasked with searching the city as
they piece together the clues they need
to attempt to reunite with their squad
mates the game was also a big shift for
the series with your character not some
cybernetically enhanced super soldier
but instead a rank-and-file fighter
albeit an elite one thus necessitating a
more strategic style of play or if
you're like me much more cowering in the
corners please don't hurt me i just know
how to die odst also featured a more
somber tone noir-like visuals and a
haunting soundtrack i mean this jazz
simply slaps
not slap jazz it just slap
you know what moving on the game also
contained top tier voice talent
featuring nolan north battlestar
galactica's trisha helfer and a mini
firefly reunion of nathan fillion adam
baldwin and alan tudyk hey where's the
fight at
i am the leaf of the wind see how i saw
her
son of a gun i'm fine watch deserve to
live on the multiplayer side halo 3
odst's biggest addition was firefight in
this horde style mode spartans fight to
stay alive against waves of increasingly
difficult enemies with halo 3 odst what
began as a small scale project became a
bonafide game that is visually and
totally distinct from the rest of the
series and one that is if nothing else
memorable
[Music]
number five halo reach for their final
game in the series developer bungie
decided to go all the way back to the
beginning with 2010's halo reach set
immediately before the original halo
reach puts players in the boots of noble
6 an anonymous member of the noble team
i'm sure they're all very noble yet
while reach featured all the franchise's
typical bombast what characterized this
entry most was its uniquely somber tone
and foreboding sense of dread anyone who
read the halo novel halo the fall of
reach knew the story could only end one
way and it made the journey of the doom
spartans all the more personal as a
result as for the gameplay reach
introduced space dogfights a new and
exciting mechanic that literally
elevated the action from previous games
the multiplayer in halo reach was as
good as ever and mix things up with
invasion where one team of elites tries
to break into a spartan stronghold halo
reach isn't the best halo game but it's
an elegant swan song from bungie to the
franchise that put them on the map also
reach featured space ostriches that
inspire their own pringles flavors so
number four halo 4. with bungie going
off to make destiny halo 4 marked the
first entry in the series to be
developed by 343 industries a lot of
pressure was put on 343 to deliver
something exciting that still felt like
halo yet put its own stamp on the
franchise beloved by so many and while
halo 4 didn't succeed in every category
343 still managed to live up to the halo
name the campaign was acclaimed for its
engrossing narrative that added to the
halo lore with the new prometheans as
well as for finally making the humanity
humanity-saving master chief actually
feel like
you know
a human instead of a robotic alien death
machine i am not leaving you here
john
the multiplayer mode wasn't as
successful it was criticized for
borrowing mechanics from other popular
shooters such as loadouts and sprinting
sprinting legasp instead of carving out
its own path still halo 4 was an
enormous commercial success and proved
that 343 was willing to forge their own
path ready to get back to work
i thought you'd never ask
number three halo 3. when halo 3
released in september 2007 fans were
ready to finish the fight billed as the
ending to an epic trilogy halo 3 not
only managed to live up to the hype but
in many cases surpassed it the story
managed to be grand surprising
horrifying and ultimately heartbreaking
as the master chief and his allies
sacrificed everything to stop the
covenant and bring an end to the flood
menace ha take that you stupid exploding
spore bags
curse you
the multiplayer was deeply refined with
enough instantly classic maps and modes
to keep college students ignoring their
homework for hours the series also
introduced new power-ups like bubble
shields to help shake up the combat halo
3 also brought with it one of the
franchise's most inventive and defining
modes
forge in forge players could create
their own maps and modes extending the
life cycle and appeal of the game for
example bernie burns of rooster teeth
used forge to create the fan favorite
grif ball mode which would go on to be
an official mode in subsequent halo
games just remember there's no i in team
griff
number two
halo 2. if the first halo game put xbox
on the map halo 2 ensured that it was
here to stay not one to rest on their
laurels bungie took risks with the
campaign by introducing the arbiter
allowing the story to explore the
complex religious zealotry and inner
politics of the covenant enriching the
thematic texture and operatic feel of
the halo universe also it introduced
this lowly video producer to the dulcet
tones of keith david what would you have
your arbiter do
all in all a huge win despite time
constraints forcing bungie to end things
on a cliffhanger setting up the
forthcoming halo 3. you mind telling me
what you're doing on that ship
sir
finishing this fight
the campaign still remains a triumph of
fps storytelling yet the most memorable
aspect of halo 2 was its online
multiplayer through xbox live a brand
new service at the time oh it's a cute
little baby xbox live with its ethernet
cables and death matches look at it so
adorable many a friendship was broken
over endless hours of halo multiplayer
on classic maps like zanzibar and
lookout oh also halo 2 introduced dual
wielding finally answering that age-old
question yes game protagonists indeed
have more than one hand truly
revolutionary
[Music]
number one
halo combat evolved the game that
started it all despite releasing 20
years ago in november 2001 halo combat
evolve still stands as one of gaming's
seminal achievements not only did this
launch title prove right out of the gate
that the original xbox was playing for
keeps it also set the stage for the
explosion of popularity of fps on
consoles this was led by the memorable
campaign that not only introduced the
instantly iconic master chief but also
managed to feel grand and open-ended yet
still grounded almost every gamer who
played halo at launch can still remember
hearing the ominous title theme or the
amazement at seeing the ring of the halo
stretch out on the horizon before you
look the theme song is copyrighted so
this is the best i can do all right
at the same time halo combat evolves
multiplayer made it the generations
first must play games with friends from
playing the campaign together to
capturing flags in blood gulch
everything that has defined halo for
over two decades is present right from
the start and went on to change the
nature of first-person shooters console
gaming and even gaming culture as a
whole while it certainly has aged halo
combat evolved still holds up as one of
the most awe-inspiring experiences in
gaming and as such nothing else could
possibly be number one on our list
[Music]
[Applause]
but certainly the joy of halo is that
while the franchise has stayed true to
its roots each entry has its own unique
personality so
what are your rankings and what did you
think of ours did we get it right did we
get it wrong did we get it so wrong that
you want to beat us up in a game of
grifball
let us know in the comments and if
you're still itching for more halo as
you wait for infinite and you want to
know how halo the franchise that built
xbox was almost not an xbox game check
out this video anyways thanks for
watching and don't forget to give us a
thumbs up if you liked it and subscribe
for more gaming content
[Music]